[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
the 183rd if I am not mistaken I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
it is July 19 2023. that's right I'm
just making sure I'm you know how like
people have a
some sort of a trauma or some sort of an
organic dysfunction the doctors asked
them to provide certain information
um they used to ask who's president for
example now I'm not sure anyone knows
but once upon a time you could use that
to assess people what was your trauma
today that prompted you to go through a
little litany to demonstrate that you're
actually of sound mind and body actually
it's interesting the trauma was I woke
up and remembered it was 2023 which is
frightening so you know it was that and
then
no no Heavens no not that I could give
you a single Factor other than one and
183 but it's definitely not Prime
61 and 3.
right nice yeah yeah all right well okay
um so yeah go uh live streaming uh right
now from Rumble if you're watching live
and uh if you want to join the watch
party go over to our locals uh which you
can find if memory serves if you're
watching on Rumble uh you can hit
subscribe now I think which is what uh
which is what join now thank you uh
which which gets you into locals and
that is where uh the the chat will be
from now on
presumably somewhere in the Genome of
slime molds there is a join now button
as well
can I just repeat that sentence back for
sure presumably in this presumably
somewhere in the Genome of slime molds
there is a button called join now yeah I
like that why so slime molds forage as
independent units and then under certain
conditions like if they run out of food
and they need to use the resources that
they have accumulated in the foraging
they join together and fruit it's kind
of cool yeah so join now I think there's
a you know there's bound to be a
methylation that's really a join now or
something like that now button yeah yeah
exactly epigenetic join now the
epigenetic join now yeah cool yeah I
don't really have much to add to that
um but they should join now I don't know
that they should at the moment no the
watch party Oh I thought you meant the
slime mold no no no no nothing like that
sorry this has been very confusing but I
think we've now we're now headed in the
same direction okay good yes yes please
join now locals watch party uh and there
will be other stuff going on in locals
as well but that is what is happening
right now uh today we're going to talk a
little bit about uh
conference that you were just at in
Memphis uh
the topics that we're going to revisit
from two weeks ago we were talking about
whether or not given that men can
identify as women and compete against
women in sports whether or not people
might start to be able to be identifying
as disabled and uh competing in the
Special Olympics well the answer is yes
unfortunately we're going to talk about
what the Deep State actually means and
um also the influence of China on
British and presumably other academics
uh and uh and therefore on what
questions get asked and what answers get
uh answered
so that's that's where we're going today
uh we're not going to do a q a today
we'll be back we're here now at 11 30
a.m Pacific on Wednesday and that's
going to be when we're doing our live
streams from now on we're going to
alternate weeks on weeks off with q a
we'll do a q a next week
and um moving everything else we want to
talk to you about
um sort of logistic wise housekeeping
wise to the end except for our ads uh we
have three sponsors as always at the top
of the hour and we are very pleased um
to have them all um they are this week's
Soul Sundays and Seed so without further
Ado here we go
our first sponsor this week is Seoul
Seoul footbeds are the original custom
moldable insoles providing affordable
pain relief since 2001.
sole footbeds include a signature
supportive Arch which is clinically
proven to produce Arch strain in your
feet and these footbeds are great for
any Arch height if you have low arches
or flat feet you simply heat mold them
in your oven at home to ensure a
comfortable level of support anecdotally
I will say that sole footbeds have been
a game changer for me I was born with
weird feet weird enough that I had
reconstructive surgery on both of them
when I was 13 which put me in a
wheelchair for months afterwards and
really truly ugly orthopedic shoes for a
year after that that surgery that was
wildly successful and I was playing
Varsity Sports within a couple years of
having it but it's been a while since I
was 13 and my arches are beginning to
flatten and my feet hurt a lot more than
they used to wearing shoes with sole
footbeds in them is helping tremendously
I have sole footbeds and my extra tough
boots and my hiking boots and even in a
pair of shoes that you might go to a
nice restaurant in they have multiple
styles for different kinds of activity
if you have any foot issues at all you
should seriously try these footbeds
sole footbeds are easily customizable
using your oven at home or you can skip
that step and they'll mold to your feet
over a few days you get the benefits of
personalized support at a small fraction
of the price of doctor prescribed
Orthotics and they're made from recycled
quark
sole footbeds also reduce pain from
plantar fasciitis and shin splints they
promote neutral alignment and good
posture and are particularly offensive
it's not a word effective at preventing
fat fatigue when standing or walking for
long hours on hard surfaces
two-thirds of people who try sole
footbeds come back for second pair and
many have trusted soul to keep their
feet energized and pain-free for more
than 20 years if you've ever wondered
whether Orthotics could add to your
comfort or athletic performance this is
your chance to find out what 17 million
satisfied Souls already know as a dark
horse listener you can get 50 off sole
footbeds simply go to yoursoul.com
Darkhorse or into the code Darkhorse at
checkout to get 50 off any full full
price pair of footbeds that's your soul
why are you are
s-o-l-e.com slash Darkhorse or enter the
code Dark Horse at checkout when you
check out at yoursoul.com save 50 on
sole footbeds today and say goodbye to
sore feet
specifically not offendive I think that
was the word that I made up yes yeah it
could be a word I don't think it's in
any way relevant to the footbeds but
yeah no I was I was I was looking ahead
and I went uh effective at preventing so
I just went with offended yeah I think
for some of us the word effective just
you know creates
what
[Laughter]
our second sponsor this week is Maddie's
all-time favorite where oh the dog is
lying on the floor behind Brett Maddie's
all-time favorite Sundays we love it too
because what dog owner and dog lover
doesn't love a product that is great for
their dog and that their dog thinks is
great too Sundays makes dry dog food
when they approached us about being a
sponsor we were dubious Maddie our dog
is a labrador Labs basically eat
anything what possible difference was
she going to show an interest between
her usual kibble which is a widely
available high-end brand in Sundays well
we were wrong Maddie loves the food that
Sundays makes son seriously loves it if
we run out of Sundays and give her her
previous iron kibble instead she gives
us a very sad look and if you know Labs
you know just how sad that look can be
she's clearly disappointed in US frankly
and
um
being a lab she doesn't want to show
that but she's disappointed in us when
we try to serve her something that's not
Sundays she knows that we can do better
we can give her Sundays and we should
not only is Sunday's Maddie's favorite
it is also far better for her than the
standard burnt kibble that comprises
most dried dog food Sundays is the first
and only human grade air dried dog food
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready to eat formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog in a pinch a person too Brett
Sundays is easy for humans no fridge no
prep no cleanup no gross wet dog food
smells is a total pleasure for the human
interacting with it which is a bonus
some of these is gently air dried ready
to eat no artificial binders synthetic
additives are General garbage seriously
look at the label all of Sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce and
healthy for dogs to eat in a blind taste
test Sunday's outperformed leading
competitors 40 to zero that sounds like
a made up number but here's the thing
Maddie was really enthusiastic about
Sundays much more so even than her other
food and it would have been hard to
predict that she could have been more
enthusiastic about food but she is she
bounces and Spins and leaps to
anticipation do you want to make your
dog happy with her diet and keep her
healthy try Sundays we've got a special
deal for our listeners receive 35 off
your first order go to sundays4dogs.com
Darkhorse or use code Darkhorse at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog so I determined in feeding the
dog earlier I guess it would have been
late last week the
uh bag that Sundays comes in is
especially triggering to the dog she has
recognized the bag as an indicator oh
well sure yeah yeah I don't think she
can read what's on it but I think she
knows that that bag with the velcro
burger no she's not a doctor no it's not
even a bunny but he's a very smart bunny
yeah all right our final sponsor this
week is seed a probiotic that really
works if you've tried probiotics before
and got nothing out of it try seed it's
designed differently from other
probiotics it's designed better it
actually works your gut and your immune
system work together coordinating your
body's response to the world both around
and within you seed helps improve the
health of your gut microbiome which
means that it supports you becoming
healthier overall our resident gut
microbes directly impact the development
and function of the immune system
even before we're born microbes inform
our immune systems teaching our body how
to distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that our bodies don't
recognize as its own as there are
my error says it right here
yeah it's the pronouns that get you yeah
it does seem to be that you can support
your gut immune axis in a variety of
ways including by prioritizing sleep new
research suggests that the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus keep
your gut immune axis healthy that is the
Axis of Awesome
you can also support your gut immune
axis by taking seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic seed is a plant-based
Prebiotic and probiotic with 24 strains
that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microbiome seed supports both gut and
skin Health seed is free from 14 major
classes of allergens including but not
limited to sugar animal products soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and corn
and seed is double hauled with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it and the
same design makes it resistant to oxygen
moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary seeds daily
symbiotic supports gut skin and heart
health and micronutrient micronutrient
synthesis we have heard from several
people who have used seed and Report
improvements to their digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours so start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Dark Horse
and use the code Darkhorse to receive 25
off your first month of seeds dso1 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com
Darkhorse and use the code Darkhorse at
checkout
very good yes I feel like
out loud it's some kind of test this is
a trauma I carry from childhood as you
know
yeah yeah yeah but I'm over it good for
the day
I probably will not end up you will
probably not have to read aloud again
today awesome yeah
so all right well then I can relax good
oh you were in Memphis this week yes I
was in Memphis this week
fascinating so I was at a conference
conference that it turns out many of the
attendees attend every year I didn't
know anything about it
until I went it's called Freedom Fest
Freedom Fest is the annual Gathering of
American Libertarians which is not
synonymous with the libertarian party
libertarian party was there and in fact
brought me to Freedom Fest but it is
people who are libertarian minded
including many people who are as I would
classify me and I think you smaller
Libertarians people who believe that
Liberty is very important but it's not a
political label for them so anyway it
was an interesting mixture of folks
there were some people there who weren't
Libertarians there were some people
there who I would classify as
Republicans there were some Democrats
there
um no go ahead I've never thought of
myself as a Libertarian you've never
thought of yourself well you know that I
mean quite explicitly quite explicitly
not and I think that was certainly true
for you until very recently smaller
libertarian yeah but then you then you
compared it to Republicans well if you
look at the uh what's it called the four
quadrant uh I've now forgotten the name
for it yeah the political COMPASS test
the political COMPASS test uh has it as
the antagonist as the opposite of
authoritarian right but that so my my
objection was that your Counterpoint was
Republican
and Democrat which sounds then like a
political uh descriptor because those
are the parties
yes
um I do believe I am certainly a small
libertarian I believe if we were to look
at your beliefs you would be a smaller
libertarian because of your focus on not
regulating more than is necessary uh
sure just not if we are describing
political parties
true and anyway
um it was a very interesting Gathering
um it was it had a number of people in
there who would not ordinarily be at
such a place it was uh they were Matt
taibi was there Nadine strassen was
there
uh I met Daryl Davis that was something
I've wanted as a person I have wanted to
meet something I've wanted to do for a
very long time Daryl Davis is the black
guy who attended ku klux klan rallies
and befriended clan members and
convinced them that they had aired and
got them to quit um anyway he's a great
guy he's also a brilliant musician
just absolutely marvelous a boogie
woogie mostly keyboards but he did an
amazing thing where he uh he snuck up on
his guitarist and uh reached around his
guitarist and took over the guitar
anyway wow quite the virtuoso
um but anyway very interesting
conference
uh I was on I gave one talk uh to a
large Al libertarian caucus they were
very welcoming of me despite the fact
that I told them that I was not only a
liberal but a radical a reluctant one as
I keep saying but nonetheless they uh
they were ready to go and and that was
all very heartening because in my past
experience Libertarians have often been
hard to reach as soon as they know that
you're not up for you know frustrating
all attempts to regulate anything uh
they they tune out but that was not the
case and it seems that as with much that
we have been seeing in the last few
years and that you and I have been
talking about as well it is hard to know
to what degree
um our understanding of them has changed
and to what degree uh the party itself
has changed yeah I think there's a
little bit of both I think there there
has always been a deeper intellectual
thread there that is not visible because
the ideological political thread is
visible and because it is actually at
some level the only viable third party
we've got
um you know it the fact of the party
does sort of overwhelm the the deeper
strands but I also think there's a
leveling up that's one thing there's a
recognition I Heard lots of talk of
things like Game Theory which is
something that I have found Libertarians
uninterested in talking about in the
past in part because one of the major
arguments against libertarianism as a
political uh mode is that it doesn't
deal with things like externalities and
the like the commons right exactly uh
Collective action problems of all sorts
um but there's a an awareness that maybe
uh Purity isn't so good and that some of
these things are necessary
um some of these things some of these
governmental interventions structures
that prevent unnecessary failures may be
desirable in spite of the fact that they
are
uh not strictly speaking
um
libertarian as a matter of policy but
anyway
um the conference was very open to folks
from other political stripes and it was
uh I think the others the other thing in
addition to the libertarian mindset may
be maturing
is that I think a lot of us are just
spooked and I certainly know that in my
own case even at not a an analytical
level but at a political level I'm more
sympathetic to Libertarians because I've
now seen uh you know a an absolutely
malignant form of governance take over
every single institution and my feeling
is you know I don't want malignant
government empowered at all right so I'd
rather have you know a an underpowered
structure so the malignancy isn't so
dangerous than have something that is uh
powerful and doing the wrong thing
but um
in any case the most fascinating thing
was that at the end of the conference
Robert F Kennedy Jr showed up in Memphis
to address the conference and that had a
kind of powerful effect of course
because he is Reaching Across all sorts
of political lines he's quite
controversial in some places but in any
case uh in fact the panel that I the I
so I gave a talk and I was also on a
panel with some some very interesting
folks
um around actually thinking through what
the libertarian party should do Thinking
Outside The Ballot Box was the idea but
anyway right after we talked Bobby
Kennedy uh showed up and gave I don't
know must have been a
35 minute talk
no notes whatsoever walked up to the
podium and just boom uh off the top of
his head and you know I as is his way a
highly specific talk in which he cited
evidence for each of his points
but the most interesting thing is he so
here he is he's a you know he's a he's a
Democrat of a kind that you and I grew
up with a kind of democrat that used to
be common and is now exceedingly rare
um and he didn't as I didn't pretend to
be anything other than I am he didn't
pretend to be anything other than he was
either and he laid out a case
which I thought was excellent I'm a
little surprised at how well it read in
the room okay so he laid out a case in
which he said the
best way to address pollution
is the free market
okay now and so far that sounds like an
easy sale in that room Yes except how
are you possibly going to have a free
market regulate pollution out of
existence well you need to hear more but
so far that sounds like something that a
Libertarian audience would be receptive
to yes definitely on the other hand you
have to you know the question is what's
the word free doing there right now the
market forces are in fact the best
mechanism for figuring out how to do
things this is a case I've made they
should never tell you what to do but
telling you how to do things there's no
tool anywhere near as good so how do you
eliminate pollution for example well
Kennedy lays out a case for
internalizing the cost for all uh
production and he says correctly he says
pollution is inefficiency
right if you're dumping something into a
river that's an inefficiency at some
part of the process that didn't have
anywhere to go and you're taking
advantage of the fact that you can
easily put it in the river and getting
it out of the river may be impossible or
very difficult
um but you know if you paid the cost of
getting it out of the river you'd never
put in the river in the first place
which is true but
I know because I've been making a
similar case I used to say if um if all
you did was internalize every cost
completely government needs to do almost
nothing else
right that's almost the only thing it
has to do and the reason that that's
almost the only thing it has to do but
it's a big thing yeah in fact it's
impossible to do it perfectly that's so
they're the devil's in the details but
if Government simply internalize all
costs right if the pharmaceutical
manufacturer was responsible for all of
the benefits that it produces that's
where the profits come from and it had
to take from those profits uh you know
some
it had to pay for the harms that it had
done in the process the harms uh done to
people who had effects Downstream and
all of that then it would be it would
have every interest in bringing drugs to
Market that were safe and effective
right if the costs of you know a cancer
that you get five years 10 years 20
years down the road are not borne by you
then uh there's no reason for Pharma to
think about it so basic point is
internalized costs result in evolution
solving problems and that's really that
he he didn't use the term evolution but
the idea is if the market internalizes
all those costs then Evolution takes
care of all the things that we don't
want all right how is the
internalization of costs
uh happening in a scenario which you
could call a free market
well that's just the thing this is sort
of an enlightened view of a free market
the point it's like a freeing a market
right the market you have to have some
mechanism for those costs returning to
the people who generated them right and
that includes things that are not even
costs risks taken right if you release
something into the public and you don't
know you know if you release flame
retardants and you don't know what their
effect is going to be then the question
is well what is the likelihood that
you're going to end up injuring people
and be responsible for uh for
compensating them down the road
so anyway the upshot of all of this is
he laid out a very good case for a world
in which markets solve problems I
wouldn't call those free markets exactly
but
what I would have expected was that
Libertarians upon hearing this case
would have had a wait a second how the
heck are you going to do that who's
going to watch the Watchers that
reaction right right the the research
being done to assess the risks and the
costs will be uh will be immediately
captured by insiders who have the
perverse incentives and you know now
you've just added more bureaucracy and
it's less free and let's lose lose right
he got a standing of it
and I don't think it's because anybody
was confused about what he said I think
there is a genuine openness that we have
now seen what happens when particular
ideologies are allowed to enact their
you know fantasy set of regulations and
you produce catastrophes and there's a
question about
oh crap how are we going to actually
govern in some way that works that
doesn't expose us to obscene harms that
you know caused somebody to
you know buy a third home but resulted
in other people's children dying right
yeah um so
I'm hopeful because a I saw a I mean
really he's one of the best orders I've
ever seen he is absolutely spectacular
he is excited but it's not obscuring
um faints or lack of knowledge or
um a desire to mislead where you know
sometimes excellent oration excellent
oratory uh covers
covers deviousness and uh I at least
have seen no evidence of that I think
there is none I think this is a
completely genuine person who is also
you know in addition to being at the
very upper echelon of orders at least in
English
he's also
extremely well versed in the subject
matter that he talks about you know
which is many many subject matters as
well right yeah and so he you know he
keeps getting flagged over stuff that
sounds too shocking to be true
but his answer is the same it's well
show me where I've got it wrong here's
what I'm going from here here's what
here's what I read yep here's how I
understand it show me where I've got it
wrong and when you do show more he's got
it wrong he does backup and change so
anyway on those rare occasions where
he's got it wrong right right on those
rare occasion and you know it's usually
not wildly wrong it's somewhat wrong
um so
I don't know what to think about all of
this I saw
I don't know how many people were in the
room many hundreds at least 500 maybe
they were closer to a thousand people in
the room
um
and
uh the degree to which they were open to
hearing from somebody of a very
different stripe to which he was capable
of laying out a case for something that
you know you can't operationalize what
he said directly right the question is
can yeah he didn't he didn't provide an
entire plan what it is is a goal right
it's like saying colorblind Society will
you ever have a colorblind Society you
know like a society with not a single
person who is predisposed to think one
way or another by somebody else's color
no but it can be an objective it can be
um you know it can be a guiding
principle and he laid out a guiding
principle and
um
did so in a way it was very hearable and
this gives me a lot of Hope yeah I think
um
there there was a kind of
there was a lot of
uh
Joy actually in this Gathering of people
hearing from folks they wouldn't
necessarily ordinarily be in contact
with and being united by a feeling of
shared purpose and maybe even shared
Jeopardy at the moment that you know a
nation on which we are depending is
clearly coming apart at the seams and
well I mean it's as you have written
about
um it is the shared Jeopardy uh which is
more likely to bring people together to
begin with than shared purpose uh in in
part I think because it is harder to
agree on the nitty-gritty of the shared
purpose and
um shared Jeopardy uh you know it is I
guess it is understood in times in
extreme times that uh hey Zach you wanna
thank you
it is understood in extreme times that
uh you're going to have to try a lot of
things and you're going to have to try
them fast and there's not a lot of time
to to go through all of the discussions
that might be called for if you're just
saying you know what we have this idea
we want to make it happen we've got some
time and so it brings people together
with a greater sense of urgency and and
once that happens I think it is easier
to see oh you know what the things that
we thought divided us aren't so aren't
so big after all
yeah
um you know I'm reminded two two threads
kind of come together
um here
there is this galvanizing
feature of shared Jeopardy
and there's also a fissioning feature of
Jeopardy and I think we are seeing both
of these things simultaneously and one
of them is extremely hopeful the the
feeling of camaraderie of discovering
that you have large numbers of people
who are actually willing to fight for
the same thing that you are is uh it is
a a marvelous feeling and at the same
time we are watching this
uh Petty at best and lethal at worst
demonization
of others the other yeah and I you know
I wasn't sure if I wanted to talk about
this um
today but I did have
uh
again we talked about it briefly some
weeks ago maybe a month and a half ago I
had gotten for whatever reason on
Twitter dumped into what I call Nazi
Twitter right
and I tweeted about it
yesterday or the day before
and I got back a reaction that I was not
expecting
first thing is people think
that I am
using that term the way it's been
leveled at people like us or Bobby
Kennedy right that I'm abusing the term
that Nazi is is a buzzword and that you
can you know you can tweak people's
amygdala by using it no no no no no no
no when I say Nazi Twitter I am talking
about a part of Twitter
where swastikas are not viewed as
negative where Hitler is quoted
in an effort to illustrate that he is
not who we were told he was in fact the
idea that is commonly circulated in this
part of Twitter is that the television
is lying to you which I'm sure it is but
the television is lying to you that
Hitler actually was not interested in
war he was interested in peace and that
the narrative that has been created
around him in the aftermath of the
Holocaust and World War II is a
construction of you guessed it Jews in
Hollywood
um right now
amazing amazing but then here's the
crazy part
that's not that's not every account okay
most of the accounts over in that land
are replying there and there are some
people over there that I know people who
have actually defended Us in some cases
these people are not Nazis but they are
now
trafficking in a kind of sophistication
or false sophistication that I know what
it is because frankly I wrote a paper on
it in college saying here is what this
impulse to genocide actually
is and I see it bubbling up and I see
people who are way smart enough to
understand that they are in fact not
they have not happened on to a place
where we need dissidents who can see you
know the true nuanced nature of Hitler
what they are is actually activating an
ancient program that lives in all people
that causes them to go after other
people who can't defend themselves
at one level of course every everything
will get gamed by claiming that it's the
opposite so this ancient
deeply tribal deeply simplistic
unfortunately human although also
primate also any social organism a way
of looking for the lines which divide
you is being trotted out as if it is the
nuanced position right that this is
nuanced like that's not nuance
it's barbaric
in
I don't even know how to parse this
thing right because
what I keep hearing is you know
if black pride is okay why isn't white
pride okay
now I know what the answer to that
question is to the extent that that
question has an answer and I know why
it's not a completely satisfying answer
but more to the point
I put out a video on Dark Horse back in
must have been 2018 in which I said look
if the woke Revolution keeps demonizing
white people as the source of all
Badness then you're backing them into
the wall together and they're going to
respond in a completely predictable way
okay I wasn't defending those people who
were demonizing white folks I actually
believe this stuff I want to live in a
country where Who You Are
at a genetic level doesn't matter and
where opportunity is distributed as
widely as possible and I want us to
compete and I want people who contribute
more to get paid more right that's not a
utopian Vision that is a place we were
headed possible it's a possible Vision
unlike a utopian Vision right
so
to watch people now trafficking in
hitlerian revisionism including you know
seriously we're talking about accounts
who have been you know in one case an
important covet dissident account it's
an anonymous account so I don't know who
who it is but
um we're talking about people who should
know better
well there's I mean there's also a
a rejection of modernity right and we
certainly you know the the entire
premise of our book
is about hyper novelty and the
particular risks of uh that the 21st
century and then most of the 20th
century have brought to humans on the
basis of reductionist metric heavy
pseudo-quantitative pseudoscientific
thinking that has led us into a badly
technological uh Universe right
but that does not mean that we aren't
interested in the modern and the and
progress right
and what I'm hearing from you talking
about this and what I'm seeing over in
um
relations between the sexes
is
okay full stop we're done all of that
was a mistake
let's go back to Trad everything racist
misogynist everything
homophobic all of it right and it can be
easy if you're not paying any attention
at all to think that those of us who are
critiquing the uh the overreach the uh
bludgeoning of people with actually new
racist things and newly sexist ideas
are are part of the problem
but it is a new
this this call to tradition this call to
what has already been is so often what
you're seeing what you're calling Nazi
Twitter and what I'm seeing and I don't
have a name for it yet but certainly
what is being revealed in a lot of the
trans ideology is this like okay part of
the problem
you know what I see oh the problem is
that women got the vote
really that's where we are we're allowed
to say that now
oh okay so guess what pseudo lefties
this is your making like this this this
is something that you have helped create
you have helped come you know bring out
into into the public with strength
because you are saying things that are
so insane that people are looking around
going like what what can I do maybe the
only thing I can do is to seek to
reverse the clock by 150 years and see
if we can't start over from there back
in the back in an era when not nearly as
many people had voices because of
immutable characteristics of their birth
and no none of us should want to go back
there but of course people are are
thinking about it
so this this was actually the subject of
the talk I gave uh in in Memphis
um
my premise was that the founders of the
American Founders almost accidentally
figured out
the formula for sidelining the most
basic form of of collaboration which is
genetic and enabling a kind of
collaboration which is indifferent to
genes and is based on reciprocity and
the idea is if you have a large
population
and you are unable to collaborate with
anybody who's well positioned to
collaborate with you has something to
bring to the table and has the features
of character that make them a good
collaborator then you're way richer than
if you had to collaborate only with
people who shared your genes right the
number of people with whom you can
partner is greater and that that of
course is a generator of wealth right
but over in Nazi Twitter it is very
common to hear that the Melting Pot is a
failed experiment now the Melting Pot is
not a failed experiment The Melting Pot
was one of the greatest ideas that
anybody ever had and you can tell that
by how much was accomplished by this yes
broken Melting Pot did we ever actually
melt together not in the way that the
founders might have expected but but we
were getting there so you know less lest
you or we sound like well the problem
isn't with Communism it's the true
communism has never been tried right
like less that we less that we seem to
be making that facile argument you are
not saying well but it wasn't really a
Melting Pot like we were we were getting
there we were moving in the right
direction and it was getting better and
better and better through at least in
you know the timeline for me sort of
starts at my Consciousness but it feels
like you know mid 70s through at least
really the millennium
we were moving in the right direction
yeah well I mean it's a question of
optimization right now there is a deep
conversation to be had of course about
the difference between optimizing
something that you've got and uh
innovating something that you don't yet
have and the real point is the West had
the thing how to accomplish it at a
practical level it had the values
spelled out and it wasn't all spelled
out at the beginning either in fact our
founding documents contain at least one
major embarrassment on exactly this
point however as I argued in Memphis you
have Martin Luther King Jr who functions
like a late arriving founder right he
completes the puzzle right his children
will be judged on the content of their
character and not the color of their
skin that is a foundational principle it
is late arriving but we had it right we
had it from before you and I were born
and to the extent that you head in that
direction
you can you gain more wealth you gain
more wealth by virtue of a even more
seamless collaboration between people
who bring different things to the table
right and the other thing is we talk
in our book we lay out the
framework of Frontiers we describe four
different kinds the fourth one having
not yet been discovered but
logically it exists the third Frontier
being a frontier of transfer where you
can't generate growth along either of
the first two Frontiers either by
finding a new place to go or by
innervating new technology Geographic
Frontier technological Frontier or this
third type which is transfer theft
transfer which transfer can mean kill
those people and take their stuff which
is what the Holocaust was and it is what
is looming whether the people over in
Nazi Twitter understand it or not it is
what is looming over there this is a
totally predictable program that will
emerge under certain circumstances and
the the idea that we have a a criminal
class in charge of our political
landscape right stealing from us left
and right in ways that we can't
understand time traveling money printer
being one such mechanism
right we've got these people stealing
our wealth right they don't want us to
come after them
and so they partner with the woke
revolutionaries who make race a focus
and begin demonizing people of course
they're demonizing you know average
whites those average whites are of
course going to react to being demonized
by gathering together and saying did you
do anything wrong did I do have why are
we being demonized right totally
predictable and that this would then
unleash this ancient program it's an
ancient genocidal program and the fact
is here's the analogy people need
this is exactly like the program for
rape
we are all all of us male and female
Downstream we are the product of many
historical rapes that is essentially
certain based on the degree to which
Warfare has played a role in our
histories
so Genetically speaking we all carry
that potential whether a female and
effectively unable to act on it or male
and have a choice whether or not to act
on it
we construct Society so that that
impulse does not manifest itself right
now
I I cannot tell you how dumb it is that
we are allowing pornographers to play
with that particular Trope because they
are making it sexy in some people's
minds which is of course going to
produce more rapes in the real world
likewise people uh Nazi LARPing on
Twitter especially at a moment where
yeah the thieves have taken the growth
we are you know eyeing each other trying
to figure out you know who's gonna get a
chair when the Music Stops and this is
all predictable but it's very
predictable and it's all just such again
facile basic like naturalistic fallacy
level thinking oh well you know it
happened therefore it must be good it is
evolution produced it therefore it must
be the thing that we ought to be doing
like no there is no there cannot be a
connection an inherent connection
between what is and what ought we we
cannot assume that and that is that is
inherent in most of these mistaken new
um new based on Ancient belief systems
and that's why I raise the analogy of
rape because any correctly thinking
person any person who has their logical
uh faculties can understand that I mean
it's so obvious that one can spread
one's genes by raping right
if you know that
you still decide hey that's not for me
that is in con whatever program I carry
that might be capable of that is
inconsistent with my values I will forgo
any opportunity that exists Downstream
of that behavior because it is morally
unacceptable to me the conscious person
and genocide is the same goddamn thing
yes we all carry that potential
undoubtedly right the question is can
you look at it and say not for me I'm
not really interested in whether my
genes for respiration you know the
particular spellings of them find their
way into the 25th Century right I will
not commit genocide on behalf of my
genes for respiration that is what
evolution will program me to do but I am
actually much more interested in what we
as people can construct can accomplish
I'm much more interested in the Feats of
curiosity of decency of compassion of
beauty all of those things those are
also things we can accomplish and we get
to choose between these two things and
if you're over in Nazi Twitter get out
remember who we are stop doing this it
is not the program you want to enact
there is nothing honorable about it and
even if you win at the end of the day
you are doing something that anyone if
we survive another Thousand Years the
people that you would most like to hang
out with the most decent the most
intelligent people will look at what you
did and they will say God damn you why
did you do that
so anyway that's my plea the idea that
Nazi Twitter is out there I'm not asking
that we shut down these people's right
to speak I don't want that it's shut
down but I do want that fraction of
people who are playing with those tropes
who are capable of thinking their way
through this to realize they are
operating based on an ancient program
every bit as much as if they were
contemplating rape that's what they're
doing
yeah
that's excellent
um
it is
telling perhaps
that
while you are discovering how much of
that is
out there now and growing
uh
that those
who would never engage in such thinking
or or actions
are being demonized as anti-semites
um and you know we already talked some
about Bobby Kennedy and I you know I
don't know that we need to connect these
things but it does feel to me like it's
it's a diversion I feel like
I feel like we are living in a landscape
of faints of you know f-e-i-n-t-s of of
you know don't look at the man behind
the curtain like there's a dog and pony
show over here there's oh you know that
anti-Semitism is bad look at this guy
who's an anti-semite when there's
actually a rise
in what's in in the hatred in the
genocidal impulses
um just out of you just where you're not
looking just where none of the media are
pointing their their
I don't even know what journalist Point
pens they don't though right like lasers
with lasers and that's not it
but uh like like
I don't see the discussion of what
you're talking about and I do see to
some degree a discussion of what I've
seen over in the somewhat similar land
around sex because there are
increasingly a large number of people
um women mostly some men who are saying
this must stop we are we are going
backwards into a land that is um very
very dangerous for girls and women and
we had won these rights we had we had
secured them and and now we are losing
them
um and so you know I do I do see
substantial pushback over in the sort of
the the sex and gender equivalent space
um but I also
see a lot of encouragement of the
insanity and
it's different with with race and with
ethnicity
because the way the media has decided to
understand it is
um is differently confused
but um you know no one no one in the
mainstream media is explicitly
celebrating anti-semitism
but they are implicitly doing so with
their choices they are inviting it yes
now the the sex and gender version of
this
maybe it's just sex really yeah
um
there's a different story to be told
right
and I think the thing with sex is
I think we
almost perfectly attained this one I
mean not you know it's an optimality
program problem but the point is women
uh women younger women your age and
younger did have an increasingly open
landscape to choose what to do with
their
time effort Talent yep life right so we
solved it at that level and I mean in
fact even in you know true circles for
for a certain class
right like you know middle middle class
and and above I think you know right
well actually this this goes back to an
old point of mine which is that the
discrimination against women
is fundamentally different than
discrimination against different racial
groups because women exist at every
level every class they may not have been
empowered in the highest class but at
the level of whether their interests
gets spoken to but I mean I think I
think there's an analogy a very clear
analogy to be made here like whereas
women exist in equal numbers at all
classes in equal ratios in all classes
uh black people for instance did not do
not right and uh there are many scholars
out there who would say actually
if you're middle class or higher
black person growing up in America in
the you know 1990s 2000s you had the
opportunities just as if you were a
middle class or or a higher woman
growing up in you know in the 1970s well
you know you you had the opportunities
and continues to manifest differently
race and sex are not the same thing
um however
if you insist as many on the you know
insane left
uh insist on doing I'm not talking about
class at all and pulling and you know
claiming to be all about
intersectionality and all of these
things but never talking about class
you of course find that black people
have worse outcomes and then you
conclude with some sort of magic trick
that that is due to a systemic racism as
opposed to saying let's talk about let's
let's talk about
um black people in class and let's talk
about women in class and say okay we
were we had gotten so close to where we
wanted to be with both of these with
with with with both demographics if you
if for people who had enough financial
stability in the home in which they grew
up that they were able to take advantage
of the opportunities that Society was
busy providing
and and those both of those but it's but
you know both of those are sliding so
let me let me uh rephrase that and see
if I've got it yeah
you had women at every class right
there are women you know uh
foreign
as much as some people would like to
pretend to forget that that's what sex
is you have just as many women and men
at every class basically except in a few
rare cultures right right uh as for
American blacks how many American black
billionaires are there I don't know but
it's going to be a small fraction of the
the billionaire class it's not going to
be equivalent to so then the racial
ratio here's the question we had a
increasingly over our lifetimes we
watched racism go from something you
know we were born into an era where you
know there was an echo of where there
was there was very deep racism left in
the air just prior to the one we were
born into right yeah Martin Luther King
assassinated in 1968.
um so and the significance of that is
not the assassination which uh at least
one court has ruled likely involved the
FBI so it doesn't have to have been a
racist
um
action that may have been a political
action but
um you know the point is the Civil
Rights Movement
in which he was deeply involved at that
moment was you know at fever pitch so
well I mean I think it's yeah that then
would be
because I think the definition of what
people mean when they say systemic
racism like you know why why would there
have been political impetus to kill uh
the greatest civil rights leader of all
time well the thing is I think I know
the answer individual I think I know the
answer and I think the answer does
involve racism but I don't want to
assume that because the fact is there's
so much money and power at stake in
governmental stuff that who knows what
the actual thought process was
um but the point is the Civil Rights
Movement was uh obviously at its peak
um at that moment and it was that
because there was lots of racism alive
and well but over the course of our
lifetimes that racism uh abated
spectacularly right to the extent that
it is where it was 10 years ago pretty
rare to meet anybody who uh spoke openly
about their racist views by and large
people had gotten over it and they
actually liked the idea that they you
know I will say that this there must be
Regional differences no doubt right no
doubt but in general I mean I don't know
what it was that did it but the fact is
you know
the
cultural mechanisms had spread
everything far and wide in the same way
that people just got very used to gay
you know gay was a big deal when we were
born it was not a big deal as of 10
years ago right it was just
a thing um and that had a lot to do with
Freddie Mercury and it had a lot to do
with Will and Grace and it had a lot to
do with uh you know Elton John and
whatever
and so the point is that people just
getting used to this stuff they get over
it and in part they get over it because
once you do as I've said before it's
like giving yourself a raise right yeah
you're paying a cost for your racism
right in part you're paying a cost
because you can't collaborate with
everybody you get rid of it and you just
feel better you worry less you have a
wider range of people that you can make
wealth with so anyway so the point is
you had women at every class much less
so it was much more skewed with respect
to race yep and the difference is that
even if you get rid of the racists right
if you inherit a level of opportunity
you are in a much worse position to
leverage it and so then you can't solve
the problem by imposing right now
requirements around you know things like
quotas right so there's some very
complex question about okay okay all the
racists vanished but I still
I don't have the opportunity with which
to get out of the situation that the
racism created right what do I do with
that what do I do so what I'm pointing
at is like yes we are in a disastrous
phase where we are toying with unmaking
all of the amazing progress that the
West made Against Racism and sexism and
clearly we benefited greatly from
putting this stuff aside the more we put
it aside the better off we did but the
interesting thing is even in
conservative circles right
you find women and men intermingling at
every level of thought and power
that's interesting we actually succeeded
and I think because the women who were
liberated from sexism were in a position
to leverage that Liberation in a way
that uh racially speaking was much less
even
um and so you know we do find many of
the voices who are arguing uh for some
sort of a return in male female space
some sort of a return which I don't
think is possible there's nowhere to go
but nonetheless some of the women who
are making these arguments are highly
accomplished women who are leveraging
the benefits of the beneficiaries of
many of the societal changes that they
would have us reverse
and that is
um that is staggering to observe and you
know I think that's a kind of
observation that is made a lot and is
often Mis misattributed but I do think
that as much as there was a lot about
um the changes in expectations around
gender norms and and sex roles in
relationships and in society in the
second half of the 20th century that
created some problems that most of us
never foresaw
the idea that you could have benefited
greatly from
um
that proportion of those changes that
were extraordinary and and valuable and
be arguing for a return to Trad is
um is striking and it you know it's one
of the things that
causes me to lose hope well but we can
be that any anyone can be so blind to
what like what allowed them to be in the
place that they are now speaking to make
sure that what like no one else can come
up behind them and accomplish similar
things but I so I think this is you're
not being dumped into Nazi Twitter
somehow you're not seeing I'm seeing it
yeah I'm not seeing the uh argument for
I guess I have seen an occasional
argument against uh the right of women
to vote but an argument leveled by men
I do not I hear women making an argument
for a return to traditional stuff I hear
lots of them right Mary Harrington
Louise Perry
uh Megan Murphy there's there's a fair
amount of this but where I hear it is
not about that's in in in in their cases
that's not who I'm who
I'm um in their case is it I think it's
more about
um
recognizing the value of choice and
returning to it or or creating a world
in which all right if I those are not
three identical thinking people right
but like but there are you know there
was a a moment
um you know maybe a caricature of a
moment in time when
um if you were a middle class American
white woman in 1950 say
um the the thing that you could choose
to do was find a husband and raise a
family and have a nice home and I'm that
is way oversimplified
um but there were plenty of women who
either because they hadn't found a
husband yet or that was just not what
they wanted to do who went out into the
workforce but it was never understood to
be the thing that was what women should
be wanting to do and I think what second
wave feminism did in part and you know I
I have thought of myself as a second
wave feminist even though you know it
came before our time
um was largely freed women from that as
the default expectation
but people argue and I have come around
to this point of view largely that it
went too far in basically demonizing the
thing that hadn't been a choice before
and it hadn't been a choice because it
is what evolution handed to us right
right so it demonized motherhood it
demonized
um being in a partnership with you know
monogamous monogamous relationship
especially with a man it demonized
Desiring to stay home for with your
children yeah if you had chosen to have
to have children and that's crazy right
so we went from you know one restrictive
um one restrictive Paradigm to a
different restrictive Paradigm and there
are many reasonable people arguing for
um both both of those options
ought to be able to be on the table just
as just as options you know anatomical
and physiological limitations aside for
the moment just as is you know there
will be some men not that many probably
but there will be some men who would
prefer to to stay home with their
children and have that be their primary
role when their children are young right
there will be many more women
for whom that would like they would like
that to be their primary role when
they're young but what I'm seeing
increasingly is that is what women want
that is what women want to do like some
women do but a lot of women don't well
and you know
the there are two
different
Foci with respect to uh the Trad women
question yeah
one has to do with uh turning back the
clock on everything
the other has to do with uh fixing what
the sexual Revolution got wrong right
and the problem is that there is you
know birth control is simultaneously a
tremendous gift
right
one that if you use it irresponsibly can
wreck your civilization but if you
leverage it correctly can liberate women
to do both things right a woman who
wants to have children and to build a
career can now control the timing of her
family and the size of her family and
the point is let me just say that often
when birth control is invoked here
um it is conflated with hormonal birth
control which it's it's a subset right
they're two different issues and
hormonal birth control has a
particularly
um confusing effect yeah it has it on
the woman who has it right I don't know
and also and everyone around her because
because hormonal differences are
smellable by us at an unconscious level
yeah no I just mean
technologically reliable birth control
right the ability to control when you're
going to produce children allows women
to contribute to many things that they
would have had difficulty contributing
to before because the timing of of uh
the production of a family was going to
be inconvenient and disrupt so the point
is you know this is it's like so many
things right what you have here is a
precious gift and what if you what you
do is you decide hey cool free-for-all
right it screws everything up right
antibiotics for everyone all the time
right yeah mushrooms yay
um yeah so that's that it's one it's one
of these things that you know let's put
it this way
um
this is complex because humans have sex
when I'm not fertile and that that is an
evolutionary adaptation before birth
control
um
so it's not that sex must equal baby
right but not at all
the fact that sex does not equal baby
that it has a relationship building
aspect in humans that is clearly
adaptive and is clearly you know it is
about other things that are important
you know they may be important because
of their effect on the quality of the
child you will raise because a
partnership that stays together and
produces full siblings is a stronger one
right but
the point is Recreation is again the
villainous concept you take really
important stuff and you turn it into
Recreation and there's enough telling
what you will ruin and again I'm not
arguing that in the case of any of the
things right I'm not arguing that you
shouldn't think you know food is
absolutely delicious that you shouldn't
um you know have you're not speaking
against pleasure like um
this this is a tough a tough one and I
think
I'd like to see you or us
drill down on that at some point I don't
know that now is is the right moment but
I don't I don't
I don't think this lands this is going
to land with a lot of people
um because it's it
I just don't think it's quite it's it's
not quite fully formulated and I will
say that I was reading some Wendell
Berry again and he was talking about
exactly this in these words from like
the 1970s about
um the move uh to make uh sex
recreational as opposed to
um and
an amazing and you know an amazing part
of a complete relationship in which that
is one of the things that you are
engaging in yeah well for those who are
looking for the delineator between what
you might hear and what I actually mean
I'm talking about the taking of things
that are complex and generative and
turning them into consumer activities
yeah right it's the consumer approach
and I'm not saying that there aren't
things that you should consume right but
there's some things that are just too
important right I would say uh music sex
food
uh hallucinogenic experiences I'm not
arguing that these things shouldn't be
pleasurable hopefully they will be
overwhelmingly so but
if you come at them as a consumer you
are actually shortchanging yourself
that's what I'm getting at
anyway I will leave it there but um well
it was a lot of topics buried in that
one conversation that was a lot of
topics and um
yeah uh
well we have a bunch more plans here I
mean we'll go I guess maybe we'll just
go briefly through other things it seems
it seems like that was sort of the
the talk for today but
um
two live streams ago two weeks ago
we in live stream 181 you discussed the
Special Olympics right and whether
someone be able to identify their way
into competing
uh
here we have
you can show Zach my screen here yep
from July 13th
princess this is at some feminist site
uh trans identified male wins bronze and
women's 400 meters
at 2023 World para Athletics
Championships so it's not the Special
Olympics but it's something equivalent
and here's the dude
um
he he goes by Valentina now uh he was
born Fabrizio
and uh and at 49 beat uh let's see uh
racing against Amara Durand of Cuba and
Alejandro Perez Lopez of Venezuela and
Fatima Zahra El idrisi that's the name
I'm going to butcher I'm afraid of
Morocco
um due to their visual disability Durand
and Lopez compared with guides who were
wearing bright yellow vests and this is
the women to ensure they stay on the
course of the track because it is the
Paralympics uh well so this guy is a a
guy
um but he also why does he get to
compete in the Paralympics like what's
his disability but Trio has been
diagnosed with stargardt disease a
disorder of the eye that causes retinal
degeneration over time
due to this visual impairment he has
been permitted to compete in both
matches designated for women with
disabilities as well as those which are
not
so it's happening there it is right yeah
this is this is a this is an able-bodied
dude who is competing against
um women with visual impairment in the
Paralympics or the para whatever it's
called the para Athletics Championships
and oh surprise surprise surprise he's
winning
so it's he's cheating twice over yeah
which
oh but poor I mean he's older than them
so
yeah I mean um
there's not even very much smart to say
because we already talked about you know
you basically predicted that this would
start to happen and boom boom there it
is yeah it's just stunning I mean the
real question is
like if I somehow decided to
um
I don't know
join some little kids track and field
and just beat the pants off them you
know because my legs are longer right
just no part of me that can imagine
feeling good about that right well I
mean we've talked about this right like
we we've talked a little bit about
these these ancient human emotions
like why where has shame gone
and why has Pride
in things that
at least used to be we understood that
you couldn't change although now this is
like these are opt-in things that you're
now calling yourself Pride proud to be
something that you've just decided you
were yesterday but like
I don't understand why Pride is the
thing that we are getting behind and why
shame is something that it would be
wrong to suggest that someone should
feel ashamed like this feels like
actually
a reversal inside me like shame is
a
an individual and societal level tool
um by which if you when you feel ashamed
of yourself
uh sometimes maybe you're wrong and
maybe you know hopefully you have
friends and family around you can say
like no no you didn't do anything wrong
like you don't need to be worried about
that but usually then that's going to be
embarrassment which is different right
like shame
is the thing that should be reserved for
oh my God what did I do
why I
can't do that how do I make it right
how do I make sure I never do that thing
again
and it feels like this no one has any
shame anymore
well
um shamelessness is a of course a
colloquially an old diagnosis you don't
hear people talk about it because I
think it's become unremarkable yeah
whereas it used to be very remarkable if
you encountered a Shameless person that
was a dangerous person because that
person was capable of doing things in
the pursuit of whatever that a normal
person wouldn't be right or a normal
adult wouldn't be you know it's the
shame that trains you to be decent yeah
um I I do have a concern especially
because Pride
is obviously
um one of the seven deadly sins right
and therefore people who have a
religious orientation think pride is a
bad thing that has now become a good
thing I don't think that's what happened
no no I don't think that's what happened
either I have and I've said this before
but like I just
I'm not proud of being a woman I don't
understand the concept of pride in
something that I had no choice in well I
mean I like I can I I can be proud of an
accomplishment of my own I can be proud
of the book that we wrote you know I can
be proud of and I it's not a dominant
emotion for me I don't think but it
could be and that's fine yeah the the
pride in something over which you had no
no choice at all
strikes me as a gamification at best
well no I think it has a uh a root that
makes sense
that has just uh
taken on a life of its own so if you
imagine the world before gay had become
normal right the world was shaming
people who found themselves gay and had
not chosen
yeah right something that they did not
have control to reverse right you should
be ashamed of yourself for what you are
yeah so it's a it's a reversal it's yeah
it's like correct no I do not I know I
should not feel ashamed and I do not
feel ashamed and I am I am in fact the
opposite of ashamed I am proud right so
that Pride standing up in the face of
those who would shame you wrongly is one
thing yeah it is quite another thing at
the point that this is no longer
considered shameful for the pride to be
an excuse to behave
uh in a gross way in front of families
and to insist that anybody who thinks
that's not cool is defective right now
you're weaponizing shame and that
reversal is
um yeah predictable enough I guess that
you know here's a weapon lying there
it's not surprising that somebody picks
it up
um but the people who benefited from the
ability to express Pride publicly as a
way of standing up against shame that
was never Theirs to Bear right those
people should now be standing up against
pride and saying look maybe this is
there's no we're not being shamed
anymore maybe this is over right yeah um
so anyway
uh but yeah I don't think it would you
know
uh I don't think
anything that you're born to is
something to be proud of inherently
right it's what you accomplished yeah
but I don't think you know there's
obviously Pride as an adaptation
there's obviously a malignant form of it
where it's you know overblown and will
get you in trouble and that's what the
religious uh uh
aphorisms are about
um but you know
pride and shame are both adaptations
they are opposing adaptations they both
have their place and out of place
they're both dangerous and that's really
the way to think of it rather than oh
pride is bad nope yeah nope it is not
inherently bad it is easy for it to
become bad
yeah I guess I you know coming
at it from a purely secular position I I
didn't it didn't occur to me that there
was of course there would be a deep
religious conviction around around the
word not the word around the concept
we've we've talked elsewhere about
things that are named either for the
first place that they were discovered or
named for the malignant version of the
thing and that these become a problem
because you can't contemplate The
Honorable version of something that has
been named around the malignant version
because as soon as you invoke it the
point is it's like oh you're on board
with that malignant thing yeah right I
mean you know social credit oh God right
I've now invoked the CCP and it's
authoritarian uh panopticon nightmare
state right right well no they didn't
invent social credit social credit was
invented by selection when we lived in
small groups and your reputation was
what you lived on
right so I don't but there was yeah that
was social credit without a uh
Central uh authorizing uh you know
authorization
party right right but but we have to be
very careful anytime you've got two
things that are close neighbors right as
an authoritarian state with a social
credit system used to allocate uh
well-beings right versus you know a
human
uh cognitive system for tracking
reliability decency generativeness
um you know that guy never helps any of
us raise barns right but uh he does ask
when he needs help right maybe we should
not be so eager to help him until he
starts helping us right exactly totally
normal and not something you can't scale
up because you can't monitor everybody's
reputation in a giant civilization so
it's something that needs something but
it doesn't need the CCP
well I mean I think yeah so social
Credit in a landscape that has been
largely commodified doesn't work right
so because because while Barn raising is
kind of equivalent between Farms
presumably in some Landscapes uh it's
still not exactly a commodity because
exactly what did you do did you know did
you show up at the same time that
everyone else showed up and really work
hard all day and you know get the thing
done or did you participate
um by showing up after lunch and hanging
out and mostly talking and then wander
away after a couple of hours you know
it's it's not a commodity and uh the way
that social credit would now be uh
observed and assessed would be
inherently a commodification yep
okay do you want to talk
about deep state or you want to save
that I think I should save it um it
needs to be fully explored and I don't
wanna I don't want to give it short
shrift but I will just ask people to
think about what their association with
that term is I've come in talking to
many people about it to realize that
there's a defect in our Collective
thinking over the Deep State and uh we
will
we will engage it next live stream and
uh that will give the Deep State some
time to prepare
well I think we're also going to hold
off on um talking about the influence of
China on British academics and Academia
um there is some
I'll just say the telegraph published a
piece this week
um that is fascinating and maybe begins
to make some sense of
um how
bad
uh some academics involved in talking
about covid uh were and behaved and
continue to behave uh during the the
pandemic so let us save that as well for
next time a week from now and is there
anything else that uh you want to talk
about
um no I think that's about it all right
well then uh
let us
let us oh
did you know that there were Sabertooth
anchovies
you know here's this is I was not going
to talk about the state so I don't have
a lot of a lot of detail here but this
is something actually research from May
of 2020. so this did not just come out
and they're no longer saber-toothed
anchovies there were there were
saber-toothed anchovies in the wake of
uh the KT boundary so you know the
Cretaceous tertiary boundary 65 million
years ago
um probably the ex the mass extinction
that was largely caused by Chick-fil-A
they never pronounced it chicksalub
um you know the big rock that hit the
planet around the Yucatan Peninsula
although there was also some stuff going
on over in India with the Deccan traps
there's a lot of stuff going on then
massive extinctions
as things began to settle and there are
all these niches open a lot of clades
produced forms that um those kids had
not seen before and among them in the
anchovy Clyde or saber tooth anchovies
saber tooth anchovies unfortunately I
have a little a little so this was
published in the Royal Society it's not
a graphic so much but then science
um has a little side of illustration
here so this is just the science news
reporting on the Royal Society paper
um and it's this is weird because they
say you know these saber-toothed
anchovies which is what's being eaten
here were actually probably Predators so
it's showing this is not a great graphic
it's just why I kind of wasn't going to
show it but um
but yeah the the saber saber tooth one a
single single Sabertooth one Sabertooth
apparently yeah no oh my goodness that
is a strange yeah a single saber tooth
on the upper jaw yeah single saber tooth
yeah out of Pakistan why
I think yeah they pierce with that and
they got all those those fancy teeth on
the bottom that they use to chop chop
their upper guns
you know I wasn't there yeah and I I
have no I did not make I thought we were
going to talk about some other side did
not fully prepare this uh for today but
um
yeah the I will post the um rail Society
paper
uh
yeah again published in May of 2020. I
will just point out that the
oh most remarkable is that this is from
the abstract of the paper sorry
published in the Royal Society uh in
2020 most remarkable is the presence of
a single massive vomerine Fang offset
from the midline in both so vomit that's
just the vomer bone so it's not quite on
the midline interestingly not quite yeah
I was kind of wondering how it was gonna
form because I was just going to say
that the Sabretooth anchovy is the stuff
of pizza nightmares no totally yeah
yeah yeah well in fact I think so as it
turns that I tweeted about this back in
2020 and someone came back at me with
that and I basically said that you knew
that there had been saber tooth
anchovies in 2020 and now you tell me I
know I for I forgot I don't know forgot
honestly I don't know how I ended up
with this open on my computer I was like
Sabertooth Andrew I was really and I
went back and it was like wait I
talked about this a little bit online
here's the thing since 2020. I know
undoubtedly we have spoken about
anchovies probably at least three times
I probably not in fact this may in fact
be the first time that you and I have
ever seen we were locked down together
for months we just must have talked
about anchovies a few times anchovies
yeah not a lot I was not a high uh level
of traffic on that topic over that
period so I mean if we're going to talk
about pizza toppings I think it's more
likely to be pepperoni pineapple even
your defense is that we never spoke of
anchovies and that's why you didn't
mention the Sabretooth variety I would
think yeah I think that's my defense
it's going to be very hard for me to
prove that's not true at this point but
I doubt it I think we spoke of anchovies
you think I was keeping you you've held
this back really yeah for this moment
I don't know for what who else yeah yeah
you can't read my mind no
okay well good saber tooth anchovies
um off the list of things we have to
mention
um but it did it did put me in mind of
so like why why is that funny right like
why is Sabertooth Andrews I'm aside from
the fact that it's actually a very
strange like single off the midline on
the vomer bone but like saber tooth
anchovy sounds ridiculous because we
have an idea of what that clade does and
even if you don't think phylogenetically
you don't think like an evolutionary
biologist you still have an idea of like
no anchovies aren't like that right
um so in that vein they're also
vegetarian Parada
vegetarian right so we had a friend in
grad school whose research was on the
plate of fishes in the Amazon that our
piranhas but there's a there's like a
subclade within piranhas that are strict
vegetarians which is also they
themselves are strict vegetarians as
opposed to I thought they ate vegetarian
they do not those ones the
non-vegetarian Piranhas May specialize
on eating vegetarians although I doubt
that yes you have to eat more than one
because they're not very satisfying
[Laughter]
no look the reason it's funny the reason
it's funny which Sabertooth energy
favorite so Sabertooth anchovy is
correct the phrase is correctly
structured to be funny yes because saber
tooth conjures something quite
frightening yes and anchovy conjures the
opposite and so it creates that little
Whiplash we call funny yeah but I mean I
think vegetarian piranha does the same
thing
yeah in yeah but it it's sort of a you
know rapidly scale up in the vegetarian
piranha case
and uh scale down rapidly in the
I'm not sure I'm not sure I understand
what the scale is there but but
um how how dangerous how important how
high a priority is that you think about
starting starting with the dangerous
Parts yes saber tooth what oh Andrew
well that's just funny I see so it's it
can be humorous if you realize that the
threat isn't what you thought it was oh
my God there's a saber tooth anchovy
whereas it might be dangerous or just
confusing if you're like oh it's a
vegetarian what piranha open it's a
vegetarian wait what again yeah
how strict does this vegetarian piranha
adhere to its vegetarian diet is it one
of these piranhas that also eats chicken
for instance
was it one day or many of it
okay
um next week we'll be back in a week
with not just our live stream but also a
q a afterwards and you can find us more
places as well there will probably will
there be a guest episode between now and
then being released I think we have
enough yeah yeah okay so I think
there'll be a guest episode coming out
probably on Saturday
uh and uh please check out Natural
Selections where I write uh most weeks
this week I wrote up I wrote a little
avian allegory about
um gulls and Eagles and the uh extent to
which the gulls will act to protect
their young from bald eagles
uh something that we should all be
willing to do for our children
um you can go to darkhorsestore.org
which is uh the where you will find The
Print Shop
based on a
the dog is moaning I don't know if she
maybe she wants some merchandise you
want like a Pfizer where the
breakthroughs never stop shirt or no the
dog does not wear stuff she's looking at
me like could you please be quiet and
let me outside now
um sigh up until proven otherwise we've
got
um a all at darkhorsestore.org uh we got
the book
we still have
um
Tour de France
I think
because the Tour de France is happening
yeah
um
you may want to check shirts that say
Tour de France it's like bike racing on
steroids
yeah so Zach Hi friend Zach is going to
um
see if that is still available well
well I remind everyone that we are now
um on locals that's where the watch
party's been happening please join us
there we still have our patreons open
um and we'll be doing
um
the private q a one last time this month
at my patreon
uh and and Brett will continue to have
conversations at at his but we encourage
you to join us there the Discord uh
which is live at our patreons in which
we're going to make live at locals but
it's not quite there yet uh it is
fantastic great group of people
uh consider checking out our wonderful
sponsors this week again three s's soul
which makes
um amazing footbeds Sundays which makes
great dog food and Seed which makes
great probiotics grown prebiotics
uh we're gonna have links to all of
those in our show notes and reminder
that we are supported by you our
audience we are very grateful to you we
encourage you to subscribe to the
channel Rumble
um if if if you're here and if you're
not come over to rumble we're not going
to get censored on Rumble and we still
have the channel open on on YouTube of
course but we encourage you to come over
to rumble join us on locals consider
liking sharing full episodes Clips
anything if you feel like you can share
with people that will actually get them
talking and thinking well that's what
we're that's what we're trying to do so
uh you find anything yet Zach
okay
um so let's uh let's get the Tour de
France uh merged back up and uh and
consider going there until we see you
next time be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone